dawn is in Gilbert Arizona hi dawn how
are you hi miss Ramsey I'm so excited to
talk to you how are you better than I
deserve
how can I help good my husband is
currently in dental school to the second
year he'll graduate in 2017
we are currently living off of the
student loans I stay at home with our
children good lord
and I was just wondering what what we do
is fart like when you graduate you only
have the student loan debt unfortunately
yes it's a private school too so we're
going to be out about 450,000 yes and so
I was wondering how do we pay that off
and buy a practice and hopefully one day
buy a home if we all if you want to stay
out of that we don't want to do
everything at once well guess we should
have thought of that before we went this
route is it's gonna be a while you go
where you're accepted it's gonna be a
while well you don't you know I mean
that I mean you gotta have me you're not
buying a practice or a house for a long
time you have $450,000 you gotta pay off
right that's how you do it I mean so
does he this partner go with like a
partner associate ship before he gets
into his own you can't afford to go
another half million dollars in debt and
by practice and a half million dollars
in debt and buy a house you're gonna
completely break yourself mm-hmm
so you've got to stop and go okay we you
know we made this decision to you know
we were accepted here and we made the
decision to go to a next not only dental
school but an expensive dental school
emerge and it's so that decision delays
homeownership that decision delays
buying a practice because you got a
dadgum huge hole you got to fill up
first right you know and there's no
avoiding this because if you go do the
normal thing you're talking about doing
go out here and you know going to have
to buy a practice and going down to buy
a house you're gonna bankrupt yourself
cuz Denton's make good money but don't
make that kind of money we're a million
and a half in debt you can't even talk
about that you've limited your choices
um so I mean you could try it but it's
going to kill you so I think you've just
set yourself in for a long winters now
I mean that's the deal so as he
graduates he's going to take an
associate or a partner or whatever where
he's got no cash outlay where they pay
him to come into the practice and then
they start writing him nice big fat
hairy checks and you guys live like
you're on college students and spend the
next few years cleaning up the four
hundred fifty thousand dollar mess
you're in Oh baby girl what a mess
Oh scares me to death money my stomach
hurt Wow